كسنائيه الماء والنار علاقه طالبان
بالنساء افغانستان رغم ذلك تجدد بعثه
الامم المتحده مساحيها لفك القيود التي لم
تستهدف مهن النساء ومستقبل الفتيات فحسب
بل مصير الشعب الافغاني لقاء القائم
باعمال الممثل الخاص للامن العام للامم
المتحده بقياده طالبان حمل تحذيرا واضحا
من ان منع النساء من العمل وحرمان الفتيات
من التعليم
سيعيقان وصول المساعدات الى كل شرائح
المجتمع في افغانستان لكن لا يبدو ان
طالبان ستتراجع عن قراراتها وخصوصا ان
للحركه موقفا متجذرا معاديا للمراه
فما استيلاء الحركه على السلطه في اغسطس
من عام 2021 بدات تحركا من منهجا لاقصاء
المراه الافغانيه وبدات معها تظاهرات
واحتجاجات ضد عمليه الت
شوربه رفعت المراه الافغانيه بشكل مبكر
مطالب الرفض وشعارات خبز عمل حريه
تظاهرات سارعت طالبان الى اخمادها اما
بالهراوات او خراطيم المياه
والاعتقالات واحيانا باطلاق النار ضغوط
وتظاهرات مقابل انقلاب طالبا على
الالتزامات وشروط المصالحه عوامل حاله دون
اي اعتراف دولي بها لكن الحركه لم تستجب
للضغوط واصدر الطباعا 16 قرارا ضد حقوق
النساء وككل قرار تحمل اجراءات طالبان
تداعيات عده وتبقى المعركه مع المراه
مفتوحه على مزيد من التصعيد في ظل اصرار
الحركه على قراراتها وغياب ضغوط قادره على
احراز اختراق يذكر العربيه